- À première vue,
Sophie Descheneauxest une joueul
élite comme les autres.
Au deuxième coup d'oeil,
on voit encore une joueuse élite
comme les autres, même si
elle est née avec une
malformation importante
à la main droite.
SOPHIE DESCHENEAUX,
joueuse de volleyball
- Ça ne change pas grand chose.
Je m'adapte. C'est pas mal...
Je suis capable d'attacher
mes lacets, je suis capable
de pas mal tout faire.
LOUIS-MICHEL BERGERON,
entraîneur équipe QC, volleyball
- Ce que je remarque, c'est que
souvent les athlètes sont
beaucoup plus à l'aise à aborder
ça avec elle que les entraîneurs
ou les adultes. La glace se
brise super vite. Puis : "Ah,
comment c'est arrivé?" "Ah,
je suis née comme ça". Et après
ça, c'est... Ça leur permet de
tisser des liens.
- À 16 ans, elle est l'une des
plus jeunes au camp
d'entraînement de l'équipe du
Québec. Bien qu'un peu timide,
elle fait sa place, à coup
d'attaques et de blocs.
Sa grande taille, sa rapidité
sur le terrain et son impulsion
sont ses plus grandes forces.
ELLE-MARIE FILLION,
entraîneur joueuse volleyball
- Moi, je pense que ça va être
une équipe qui touche le plus
haut. Malgré que ce soit une
première année, je ne crois pas
qu'il y en ait qui touche le
plus haut.
- C'est une des meilleures au
Québec, point. Avec ou sans
main. Donc, ça, c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même assez
exceptioexceptioexceptioexceptis
un frein du tout pour elle.
On dirait que c'est juste
naturel pour elle de continuer
malgré ça.- Elle frappe de la m,
une bénédiction au volleyball,
où les gauchères sont rares.
- Elles sont droitières, fait
qu'elles sont positionnées pour
les droitières. Fait que dans
le fond, quand tu es... Tu sais,
j'ai des différents angles,
je peux aller chercher des
places qu'elles sont moins
habituées en tant que tel.
- La joueuse de St-Lazare, qui
ira jouer au Cégep Edouard-
Montpetit cet automne, a
pratiqué plusieurs sports,
dont le soccer, le plongeon et
le ski. Mais elle préfère
la camaraderie du volleyball....
- Ce que j'aime, c'est vraiment
l'atmosphère avec l'équipe.
Quand on célébre un point,
c'est toujours le fun. Aussi,
quand on fait les
et quand les autres font
les bons coups, on dirait que
c'est tant plus le fun de
célébrer le coup des autres.
- Sophie ne sait pas jusqu'où
la mènera son sport.
Elle vit au jour le jour.
Mais à court terme,elle aimeraiu
Québec monte sur le podium aux
Jeux du Canada.
Ici Antoine Deshaies,